morning all nearly
90 of head teachers believe the
government is
not going far enough to help schools in
england recover from the pandemic
that's according to research from the
national association of head teachers
shared exclusively with sky news well
last month
ministers unveiled a 1.4 billion pound
package to help children catch up with
lost learning
the government describes the recovery
plan as ambitious
and says total funding exceeds three
billion pounds when added to earlier
pledges
but as our people in politics
correspondent nick martin found it one
primary school in cheshire
many teachers are struggling to meet
their people's needs
this was the desk i had quite a small
desk
and i was just starting my laptop and
wishing i could go out and play liam has
spent
months learning at home but now we know
staying off school for a long long time
and doing homeschooling isn't actually
as good
there are 540 pupils at woodlands this
is a large
primary school in elsmere port in
cheshire by the time the pandemic is
over
most of the children here and millions
more across the uk
will have missed months and months of
time in school
you know children have spent so long out
of the classroom that no amount of home
schooling can match this so we're going
to start maths now
during lockdown only vulnerable children
or those of key workers
were allowed to come in the rest had to
be home
schooled my mum was actually really good
my
brother liam he helped me with my
phonics we got a pack of little phonics
cards so i could practice at home
jessica's seven she's missed a lot of
school
especially crucial phonics lessons
that's the method schools use
to teach reading and writing you worry
that you know academically they're not
going to be able to
to keep up maybe with some of the other
children you worry
that you've not done enough
homeschooling you're worried that you've
not kept their spirits up enough you
worry that they
you worry about everything what was our
target number that we started with
yesterday narula
initial findings from research done by
the national association of head
teachers
shared exclusively with sky news reveals
that 87 percent of school leaders
said the government's covid recovery
funding was not sufficient to meet the
needs of their pupils
they also found that an average school
is down by nearly sixty thousand pounds
since the pandemic began that's the
extra cost of covered security
supply staff and lost income from not
being open to the community
schools were already under financial
pressure beforehand
so now if you wanted to put in
additional support for children
you'd be hard pushed too because most of
us have spent extra cash on cleaning or
you know ppe stuff etc etc
because whilst the government have
committed money to us it just hasn't it
hasn't
fulfilled that shortfall the government
is putting 3 billion pounds into schools
which includes extra catch-up lessons
but teaching unions say
this isn't enough nick martin sky news
a bit of breaking news for you in the
last couple of minutes the office for
national statistics has published the
gdp gdp figures for me our man in the
know
our business correspondent paul kelsey
has the details uh paul what are we
learning
uh yeah uh uk gdp in may these are the
figures from may
this year grew by naught point eight
percent nil now it's lower
than uh many economic forecasters were
expecting they were almost
double that was the the expectation 1.5
just
0.8 percent that's still 3.1
below pre-pandemic levels of the economy
back in february 2020 but it is the
fourth
consecutive month of growth in the
economy of course there's a good reason
for the fact the economy is growing is
the unlocking
uh of the economy began uh in certainly
continued a pace in may
the service sector has driven this
increased services up nearly one percent
0.9
in may the really the figure that jumps
out is that accommodation and restaurant
trade jumped 37.1 percent in may
again uh that may 17th date was a step
on the roadmap when uh
accommodation could begin letting rooms
overnight to people and restaurants
could
open up again there are some uh
continuing
little warning signs about the state of
the economy in
here uh manufacturing uh is uh
fell in may 16.5 and one of the reasons
for that is this microchip shortage that
we've talked about
occasionally a shortage of the
processors that go into almost
everything we buy nowadays they've held
up the car
uh production around the world and
production and delivery of electronic
goods so
far from out of the woods but a fourth
month of economic growth for the economy
and we'd expect these figures
oh we appear to have lost paul but
thankfully we got most of what we needed
to know from him
uh joining us this morning with me hope
fewer audio problems uh the transport
secretary grant shaps mr shaps good to
see you this morning um
somewhat appropriate that we come off
the back of the gdp figures and a week
of big announcements
yours yesterday certainly one that
people are hoping will give a shot in
the arm to the economy just just take us
through the thinking
uh behind that which you announced
yesterday particularly as regards the
the the lack of requirement for people
coming back double vaccinated
from ambulance company countries to
isolate
yeah well that's right i mean up until
now if you've gone to an amber this
country
uh we'll start we said you shouldn't be
going there for holidays but you also
had to come back and you had to
quarantine or self-isolate what we did
yesterday on the basis of the fact that
we now have
such a large proportion of uh of people
um fully vaccinated it said if you have
been fully vaccinated
then you can essentially travel from the
19th of july
to an ambulance country without needing
to come back and quarantine you'll still
need to come back and take a day two
pcr test but that will of course open up
large number of countries which fall
into that amber category by far the
biggest group
between the red amber and green so good
news for people who are looking forward
to maybe seeing loved ones abroad or
even
catching some sun but what though of
of loved ones who who live abroad and
come back here as you say you're talking
about people who are fully vaccinated
but fully vaccinated
via the nhs i think at the moment there
are around about 30 countries that
accept
our certification why won't we accept
anyone else's
well that would be phase two of it and
something we're very actively working on
at the moment of course with the uk
vaccination program
we're able to you're able to demonstrate
your vaccine status very easily the
full nhs app that's not the covert app i
should
point out it's the regular nhs app app
contains your
record for your uh vaccines so once
you've been fully vaccinated it
effectively gives you a certificate
which you can show on screen or download
so it's easy for us to be able to use
that in order to demonstrate the status
for
somebody returning home uh that's the
first stage the next thing is to be able
to recognize
uh apps from other countries or
certification from other countries
easier done from some places like the eu
where they have a digital app coming
along than it is in the united states
where they have i think 50 different
systems one for each state
largely paper based so there's some
complexities to work through there but
this is phase one and
we hope to follow it up quickly with
double vaccinated people
from other countries coming here
can you put some sort of time frame on
that because clearly
a lot of people are looking forward to
your announcement yesterday they may
well have some time off coming in this
summer
there are an awful lot of expat brits
wanting to come back to the united
kingdom to see their family
do you think you're going to be able to
have this done what next couple of weeks
next couple of months
by the end of the summer yeah so i mean
first of all this announcement kicks in
from the 19th of july for anyone who's
been vaccinated in the uk
and then secondly we're actively working
on this issue of um how to accept
uh vaccinations from other people
obviously we look at whether they are
uh world health organizations certified
and like
and i i would think in terms of time
scale in the next couple of weeks i'll
be able to come forward and say more
about
other locations in the world do you
understand though
the frustration of expatriate brits for
example
living in italy this weekend we're going
to see around about a thousand
italian fans coming to this country to
watch the football
and then heading straight back home
afterwards
there will be thousands of people
looking at that and saying well why
can't we do the same
people who perhaps haven't seen their
families for the best part of a year and
a half
yeah yeah no i mean look we want to be
able to open that up for people and
actively working on it i should say with
the with the football um
they come to a specific location they're
taking direct to the football
uh they leave again 12 hours later there
isn't
any they're unable to travel anywhere
else et cetera it's a very restricted
um program but nonetheless i'm going to
take the point and i think we do want to
get this done part part of the issue of
course is elsewhere
the level of fully vaccinated people
tends not to be at the levels that we've
got in the uk
because we got on with our vaccination
program so much faster
so you know there aren't as many fully
vaccinated people
for example from europe to come here but
nonetheless we are working on it we do
want to get
this part of it resolved as well i
thought it was important with this phase
one
section you know people who've been
vaccinated in the uk
to get that information out there as
soon as we were ready to make the
announcement which is why i did that
yesterday
but i said we'll follow up with phase
two for people coming the other way
as soon as we can just explain as well
if you can
uh minister the the rationale for for
asking for a pcr
test from children as young as five six
years of age
yeah so first of all i should point out
the um
children 18 year olds and under oh
under 18 of course children will be able
to follow the same rules
regardless of whether they've been
double vaccinating of course the answer
is they won't have been double
vaccinated because currently
the joint committee on vaccines and
immunization have not recommended yet
vaccinating
um children and we're waiting for them
to opine on it so we thought it was
right and proper
because they can't be vaccinated to
allow them to adhere to the same rules
but we must of course make sure that
we've got protection
uh for you know everybody in the united
kingdom in place
and a pcr test remains the best way to
do that and it does mean that we're able
to then
uh keep a very close eye on those
variants of concern
which are of course the thing that we
are most worried about now we don't want
to put the country
at risk and that could be carried by a
child as well
so that's the reason why we're doing it
and this is the reason why everybody
will still have to take a pcr test on
day two
when they return in indeed you mentioned
a couple of minutes ago the
the the the nhs uh covert 19 app and
you'll have seen you'll have
i'm presuming actually below have had
conversations about this with with
people in your own department about the
concerns that
when we get into this summer and we see
as the health secretary outlined cases
perhaps running as high as a hundred
thousand new hundred thousand new
cases a day perhaps even higher than
that that we are going to be in a
position where we are seeing potentially
millions of people
and certainly not the majority of them
with covert 19 but millions of people
being forced
to self-isolate what action is being
taken on the app at the moment
yeah that's right i take advice on this
or i we take advice on this from
um the medical um experts and you know
as
things like um the the the overall
nationwide levels for things like uh the
the amount of distance that you need to
keep the social distancing and other
rules
are looked at so will we look at the way
that the app
performs with regard to what are now the
new standards uh being in place
so always keep a very close eye on those
sort of things i i did
um speak to the health secretary about
it yesterday he's very aware
of this and uh we will keep it under
constant review because
um we want the app to be a useful um
tool in our armory
uh to make sure that we're all able to
uh be aware of and ultimately defeat the
coronavirus and we want it to keep
continue to work in that way
yep so sorry to interrupt mr we're just
a bit pushed for time but but people are
deleting the app as we speak people are
switching off the contact tracing aspect
of it it is fine that
there will be some tinkering we're told
that it will be less sensitive
uh in future but you know if people have
deleted it from their phone they're
unlikely to be putting it back
on it just feels like we might have
missed the boat in this one
that's not actually the evidence by the
way we're still seeing lots of people
downloading the
app encourage people to do so as to say
we'll keep the
sensitivity of it under review to align
with the new
um recommendations that come in
guidelines to come in on the 19th
of july so we'll continue to do that it
is very useful tool in the army and no
one wants to get
long covered no one wants to get covered
and pass it on somebody who becomes
seriously ill or worse dies so it's in
all our interest to carry on
using every tool that we've got to
defeat coronavirus
and the the app will remain an important
part of
of our armory to do that and we
encourage people to carry on using it in
the same way as we encourage people to
keep applying common sense you know all
the things we know about better outside
than indoors and all the rest of it
and the absolute another part of of that
of that armory
i do i do want to finish off our
discussion this morning if i can
transport secretary
on your brief and and about public
transport over the past couple of days
you will have seen
a number of groups that are interested
you know perhaps representing those who
are
immuno-suppressed representing people
who were in the vulnerable category
before
the removal of the removal of the
mandating of mass on public transport
is petrifying vulnerable people up and
down the country
what would your advice be to those that
have to travel by public transport who
fall into that category
would you simply say that they should
travel off peak
yeah for start we'll still be issuing
guidelines and
as with everything to do with
coronavirus similar to the conversation
we're just having
um we've been living with this for a
year and a half now people know
uh the things to do in order to try to
keep themselves
safe and it's still sensible to wear a
face covering if you're on a crowded
piece of transport a crowded tube for
example
um but clearly if you're on a train on a
perhaps a long distance
service there's no one else in the
carriage um this is not really
protecting anyone we're able to now
shift to people using their own common
sense
uh increasingly as we get through the
19th of july
uh and asking people to do that so i
think it's right that we switch these
things
from the law to guidance but nonetheless
that doesn't mean that we're not guiding
people to
to be sensible uh and to think about how
they can protect themselves
and others um but recognizing the fact
that
the majority of adults have now been
double vaccined and of course
reminding people to come forward for
their vaccinations and their final
vaccination if they've had the first one
i can't have a government minister on
the program without at least once
referencing the football coming up on uh
on sunday um i won't ask you for a
prediction for the uh
for the result but strange reports
circulating this morning about people
pushing
perhaps for a bank holiday on monday if
uh
if england do perhaps allowing people to
come in slightly later
for work what do you think well i
wouldn't want to jinx it i think is what
i'd say
we're all not in my lifetime i don't
think in yours have we been in this
position
i don't want to say anything that's
going to uh make any
presumptions at all and good luck to
england on sunday we'll we'll be right
behind you
yeah nicely sidestepped uh grant shapz
good to see you this morning thanks for
being with us thank you thank you
still to come on the programme a
coalition of military charities have
called on the government to strengthen
legislation
aimed at protecting members of the armed
forces at half past i'll be speaking to
matthew sears of the royal british
legion
as well as a former royal marine
ofcom received a record number of
complaints about programmes in the last
year
its chief executive will be telling us
why at quarter to eight
and at half nine we'll be speaking to
the writer candice braithwaite
on her new book of essays offering the
advice she wishes she'd been given
growing up
as a young black woman
[Music]
seventeen suspects including fifteen
colombian nationals have been detained
in haiti
in connection with the assassination of
the country's president jovenal moyesi
who was shot at his home on wednesday
uh our correspondent laura bundik is in
the newsroom with more for us laura tell
us what you know
the nation haitian police have been
looking for those responsible there's
been a massive manhunt
and a gun battle on the streets of the
capital porter
porter prance the police now say they
have uncovered
a highly armed international hit squad
which they believe
was behind the killings and they've
paraded the 17 people they've arrested
so far of these people 15 of them are
said to be from colombia
and it's reported that they are former
members of the colombian army
those paraded also included two haitian
americans as well we understand that
three people
from this unit have been killed and that
there are further
eight still on the run we don't really
know
the motive yet behind the assassination
or what the link to colombia is at the
moment
but the haitian police are saying this
was a heavily
uh armed and a highly trained group of
people
behind it they've also put on display
some of the weapons this huge
arsenal of weapons that was discovered
this arsenal included machetes assault
rifles they seized mobile phones and
passports as well
the 15-day state emergency that was
declared in haiti following the
assassination is still underway we don't
really know
who will succeed the president at the
moment he wasn't
universally popular there'd been
protests quite recently calling for his
resignation haiti is one of the poorest
countries
in the region i think the real worry now
is that this
incident will mark the start of another
violent chapter
of instability in the country order
thank you
the police watchdog has told sky news
two members of the metropolitan police
have been served with
misconduct notices over potential
failings in the disappearance of
teenager richard okarogi
the 19 year old who'd been shielding
during the pandemic
went missing after leaving his home in
west london in march
his body was found in a lake in epping
forests in essex on the fifth of april
our correspondent aver bennett has the
story
it's more than three months since
richard corrigay's body was found
the circumstances around his
disappearance and death still aren't
known
but as police continue their
investigation they too are under the
spotlight
and the probe into how the met first
handled the case has now seen
two members of staff served with
misconduct notices
for potentially failing to pass on new
and relevant information
the internal investigation was launched
after complaints made by the 19 year
old's mother
who accused the met of not treating her
seriously when she reported her son
missing
that was a joke
they treated me like i was one
lunatic do you think race played a part
race did i feel so
i feel so
discriminated her son disappeared after
leaving home in west london on march the
22nd
the student who had sickle cell disease
was last seen on cctv that night in
laoton and essex
following an extensive police search his
body was found two weeks later
in a pond in epping forest nearby
richard's mother contacted the police
the day after he vanished but he wasn't
officially recorded as missing
until 24 hours later reacting to the
misconduct notices
she said it is encouraging to hear that
they are doing something
because i kept calling and at one point
a police officer told me to stop
this news provides some vindication of
what i said all along
about how slow the police were to act
misconduct notices don't necessarily
mean disciplinary action will follow
but this is a welcome step for a family
that's still searching for answers
either bennett sky news
uh time for some of the day's other news
now the risk of severe illness and
death from covet is extremely low for
children and teenagers
according to the most comprehensive
analysis of public data
researchers suggest it means the vaccine
needs to be shown to be extremely safe
to be rolled out to under-18s
well let's take a look as we always do
at the latest coronavirus data for the
uk
there have been 32 551 new covert cases
in the most recent 24-hour period
35 more deaths have been reported that
means the total number of people who
died within
28 days of a positive test now stands at
128
336.
now we'll hear all the latest
vaccination figures they show another 86
953 people received their first jab 171
477 received their second
in total 34.2 million people have now
received both doses
of a covered vaccine let's take a look
at the link between cases
and hospital admissions uh well in the
latest week
2.7 people per 100 000 covered cases
were admitted to hospital
that compares to 7.7 at the same point
at the start of the second wave towards
the end of october
and while the number of people dying
with covid19 has increased
the number of covert deaths as a
proportion of infections
still 10 times lower than it was in
october
the olympic flame was greeted with a
low-key ceremony when it arrived in
tokyo earlier today
it follows the announcement that
spectators will not be allowed to attend
the games due to a recent surge in
coronavare's cases
the absence of crowds clearly matters to
some olympic hopefuls
including the australian tennis dart
nick kirios who's pulled out of the
games
saying that playing without spectators
doesn't feel right
uh time for a quick run through some of
the front pages starting today with the
guardian it leads
with the relaxing of quarantine rules
and how a hundred countries will soon be
open for holidaymakers in
england to visit once again
according to the telegraph the
chancellor rishi sunak is encouraging
people to return to the office
when work for home rules at work from
home rules change on july the 19th
here's the mail it understands the
redesign of the nhs covert app could
spare
thousands from isolation story we were
just discussing with the transport
secretary
elsewhere papers are leading with the
football the middle splashing with
fever pitch original as fans call for a
bank holiday monday
if england win uh the sun
welcomes that possibility with guess
what a pun
three lions and with its tongue firmly
in cheek over england's italian
opponents the star
asks this what have the romans ever done
for us
a time to see how the weather is looking
this friday as we edge into the week
all the details morning joe good morning
good morning
well i'd love to say that the weather's
fantastic but it's not really it's uh
annoying
a lot of showers around so you never
really know who's going to get the
showers
and some of these could be heavy could
be thundery uh so let's
take a look at what the forecast says
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
hello there good morning to you well
it's not really what we expected this uh
time in july but uh until end of next
week we could be seeing some more
settled
summary conditions but for the time
being showers longer spells of rain
this morning we're mostly cloudy through
many northern and western parts with
some
showery outbreaks here and there it's
also very warm and muggy this morning
quite uncomfortable
during the night central southern
eastern areas seeing brighter skies and
this is where we'll see the highest
temperatures
of around 24 or 25 degrees celsius
that's 77 degrees
fahrenheit but it's also in these
brighter spots that we'll see the
showers being triggered
so those showers becoming more
widespread through the course of the
afternoon
whereas northern and western parts
really just stay rather dull
later on we see those showers starting
to die away only as cloud increases
towards the southwest and we see some
fairly heavy rain coming in and this is
going to track its way eastward
overnight
reaching parts of west sussex by morning
and then pushing on towards the
southeast
further north sunshine showers once
again
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
welcome back in the last half an hour
i've been chatting with the transport
secretary grant shaps
and he confirmed that the government is
currently working on allowing the uk to
accept
vaccine certifications from other
countries
in the near future it comes after
bookings for holidays to ambulance
destinations increased
by as much as 400 percent after the
government announced travel from the uk
will become quarantine free from the
19th of july for those
with double vaccinations here's what mr
schaps told me
the next thing is to be able to
recognize apps from
other countries or certification from
other countries easier done from some
places like
the eu where they have a digital um app
coming along
than it is in the united states where
they have i think 50 different systems
one for each state
largely paper based so there's some
complexities to work through there but
this is phase one
and we hope to follow it up quickly with
double vaccinated people from
uh other countries coming here this
announcement kicks in from the 19th of
july for anyone who's been vaccinated in
the uk
and then secondly we're actively working
on this issue of
how to accept uh vaccinations from other
people obviously we look at
whether they are uh world health
organizations certified and like
and i would think in terms of time scale
in the next couple of weeks
i'll be able to come forward and say
more about other locations in the world
our political correspondent rob powell
was lurking in the wings listening to
the transport secretary
so there we have it from from the
horse's mouth two weeks
and we should expect to start seeing
some movement on this yeah and this will
be a big deal for
brits that are living abroad expats that
maybe want to come back and see family
also people that want to come back and
see friends and family that
have had a vaccine and are not
necessarily
brits but live abroad anyway and they
may well be wondering why
they still have to quarantine even
though they've had the same stuff going
into their arms
just in a different country and under a
different health service but more
details hopefully
in the next couple of weeks it does
sound like this is more of a paperwork
or administrative issue
than necessarily an issue around
principles of travel
also grant shaps confirming as well what
have been speculated in the last day or
so
that the nhs app the covid app that is
that will ping you if you've come close
to someone that's tested positive
for covid that that will be tailored so
that it fits
the new rules after july the 19th so
it's not quite clear
what that'll mean whether that means
that the
distance you have to come into contact
will be relaxed slightly or if the
number of minutes you have to be there
will be relaxed slightly
as well but as you pointed out to the
transport secretary the horse may have
already bolted on this one
that people may be worried about getting
pinged up 62
week on week towards the end of june and
if people have already started deleting
that app then they may find its use
starts to deteriorate
certainly me thanks very much rob more
from you throughout the morning of
course
but for us a coalition of military
charities
is calling on the government to
strengthen legislation aimed at
protecting members of the armed forces
in an open letter signed by
organizations including the royal
british legion and help for heroes
mps have been urged to widen the scope
of the armed forces bill
currently going through parliament uh
pleased to say that we're joined now by
the assistant director of public affairs
at the royal british legion
matthew seward matthew good to see you
this morning um
if you could just just take us through
the the aspects of the armed forces bill
that you suspect are somewhat lacking at
the moment
yes the armed forces covenant is a
promise from the government and the
nation to those
who serve have served and their families
that they should not face
disadvantage as a result of that service
and that special consideration may be
appropriate
in some circumstances especially for the
injured and the bereaved
up to now that's been a largely moral
obligation and what the government's
doing in
the armed forces bill before parliament
now is strengthening some of that into a
legal requirement
on councils and some other public bodies
in some areas
of health housing and education now
we and as you say 11 other major armed
forces charities have come together
today to say that we think that needs to
go
further uh that it should be including
national government and all the issues
which may be affecting the armed forces
community
if it's to truly reflect the way both
the way they access services
and their needs you would concede though
i'm sure matthew that the way in which
we treat our service men and women has
has improved a considerable amount over
the past three decades
absolutely uh we as an organization the
british legion we campaigned for the
covenant to be originally included in
legislation a decade ago now and
it's definitely the case that there have
been many advances and improvements
which have been made as a result of that
and
there has been a a big change in the way
that we uh support our armed forces
community
over the last decade we want to make
sure that that progress is maintained
into the future
and that as the nation changes and the
nature of the armed forces community
changes
that it's sustained uh for the long term
what then
when when the legion speaks to to
veterans as you obviously do on a
day-to-day basis
when you speak to veterans where are the
biggest pressures on them
on their lives once they make that
return to civilian life
i think one of the things i mean the
first thing to remember is that many
many people who have served the armed
forces gained many positives from their
service
whether that's the comradeship of those
they served alongside
or whether it's the skills that they've
acquired which enable them to make a
great contribution to society and we
have
we've seen yesterday the announcement
about afghanistan over the last two
decades 150 000 uk
personnel served in afghanistan so we
can't generalize too much about their
experiences but
for those minority who do have
difficulties and who come to us for
support
what we're increasingly finding is a
range of different complex needs and
this is
why we're making this point about this
bill so for instance somebody may come
to us with a
housing issue but at the root of that
might be an issue to do with finance or
accessing benefits or how they're
dealing with compensation and there
could be
other health problems related to that so
just narrowing the scope of this bill to
very specific discrete areas health
housing and education
doesn't really reflect the reality and
the complexity
of the way people need support i suppose
the
the one thing that stands in your favor
all over this matthew is that the public
does broadly support the armed forces in
a way you know i recall
you know shortly after the iraq war
first kicked off you know people in
uniform being abused being spat out in
the streets we are a country mile away
from that in terms of the public's
regard
for our armed forces nowadays
absolutely and obviously we as an
organization we see the generosity of
the public every year when we have the
poppy appeal and throughout the year as
well
and obviously as we've seen over the
last 18 months as well you know the
contribution of the armed forces
uh during the pandemic in terms of the
delivery of the
testing and the vaccine rollout but also
the symbolism of someone like captain
sir tom moore
and what that can bring to the country
as well so um absolutely
yeah that's it and i think that has
changed as we've obviously been through
a period of
a number of significant conflicts over
the last two decades
we certainly have uh matthew stewart
from the royal british legion good to
see you this morning thanks being with
us
well let's go and get the thoughts well
from the forces themselves uh ben mcbean
is a former royal marine who was himself
injured in an explosion in helmand
province in afghanistan
back in 2008 really pleased to say that
ben joins us on the program ben good to
see you this morning
good morning how are you i i'm very well
i suppose i suppose i should be asking
the question of you um in in in as much
or as little detail as
as you like would you would you mind
just telling us a little bit about your
story and
and that which happened to you out in
helmand
yeah i was um i woke up one day in
afghanistan i've been there for a couple
of months
and um just had like my own voice just
told me that morning that something was
going to happen
but you can't obviously do anything
about it just went out on patrol um
a couple of hours later my right leg was
blown off
my left arm was in estate um
yeah i'm now a double amputee career
over
um almost my life was over but
i've just tried to obviously since then
not bounce back but just move forward i
suppose um and just try and
make the best of the rest of my life
that's it and how much have you been
able
to do that i mean you're smiling with me
this morning but i'm looking at pictures
presumably taken pretty soon after um
what happened in helmand um
you're smiling right now but i mean i i
suspect it's been a bit of a bumpy road
to get to this point
yeah i mean i suppose the cost of
overcoming adversity
um it cost a lot you know for me to
smile for me to walk to the shop i've
got to put a lot of work i've been
injured 14 years now
which is a long time and yeah
it's been hard work all the way but
my options you know i can just give up
and just
you know just sit there all day or at
some point i have to kind of move
forward i've got two kids now and
i need to be there for them and even
before they were born i need to be there
for myself and just enjoy what's left of
my life or else it's kind of
a waste of the the lads that the doctors
the surgeons
nurses saving my life it would have been
pointless if i just jumped out of one at
the end of it so
yeah it's hard work um i do have my down
days and you do reflect and think oh man
i wish i never got injured kind of thing
but
it is what it is and as i say i'll just
try and make the most of it
do you feel that we were just obviously
speaking to matthew from the royal
british legion there about the armed
forces bill
do you feel that the military covenant
in your case
that we've held up our end of the
bargain that the government has held up
their end of the bargain that we send
you off to places
like helmand knowing that you risk
having injuries the likes of which you
experience
but the quid pro quo is when you come
back we look after you do you feel like
we have
um yeah i suppose to a degree yeah i
mean the thing is it's a bit like
you know i just think we did the best
job that we could do with what we what
we had at the time
and i think the government maybe could
have done more but when when they
realized they hadn't done more
i suppose they kicked in and sorted
themselves out
as the years have gone on things have
adapted things have changed and
i think that's the main thing if
something that needed to be there wasn't
there
um now it's probably there or they're
looking into it
if they were saying no just leave it
then that's the problem but i think
now most kind of issues they're being
looked at or resolved
so yeah as i say i mean i posted a tweet
the other day saying i'm not sure if the
war was even worth it but
i think now looking back you know as a
troop as a soldier on the ground
our battles were just with let's say it
was 10 of us royal marines versus 10
taliban
it was that was our war we didn't get to
see the bigger picture
and we wasn't really interested it was
just fight our own battles and i think
over the years with the wars we've just
done the best job we can do with what
we've got
and i think the government are now
looking to listen to us for once and
they're doing the best job now that they
can do i believe
it must be there must be bittersweet to
see the end of british military
involvement in afghanistan given given
the state of the country i mean i spent
some time with 4-2 commando
out in helmand you know a few years ago
now in that particular tour
they lost you know plenty of your
colleagues i mean that must that must be
bittersweet for you
yeah i mean it's the thing it's like um
you know to gain a kilometer a guy might
die or someone's lost their legs or
whatever like myself
and obviously now if we just leave
they're just gonna take that kilometer
back
so you think oh what was the point um
but again if you look it like that it's
kind of disrespectful to the troops on
the ground because
we fought hard to gain that kilometer
and we did a good job kind of thing so
i'm glad that we're kind of out or
backing out now because it saves more
people being injured like myself or
killed and
people's mental health 10 years down the
line goes down the pan
families that have been devastated um
where'd you draw the line
um you know i'd like i don't feel like
we like you know we won the war kind of
thing
um but i just think we did a good job
whilst we were there and i'm just glad
it's kind of over now because it just
saves any more
um drama because my injuries last
forever mentally physically emotionally
and obviously if you're dead your
families that their kind of emotions
it's it's a lifelong thing so i think
the line's been drawn and i i've got no
complaints
and ben before we let you go i mean i
know that you know but next commandos
that you know they're ingenious they can
you know can turn their hand to anything
i am told however
if england win the football on sunday
you're going to be using your prosthetic
leg you know in a way that it perhaps
wasn't entirely designed for
yeah i'm not sure if i should have said
that i've got i kind of had too many
beers
please tell our viewers i said yeah yeah
i i said i'd
um fill my prosthetic leg up with with
liger lager
um i think you fit about 10 points in
there and i was going to neck it
so i'll have to if you win i'll give it
a good wash and i'll fill it up and i'll
i'll neck it and i'll post it on
my twitter page so yeah we'll see
fingers crossed i'll have to do it to
win
oh dear lord i've done a few yards
available in my time but nothing like
that i wish you all the videos
ben great to see you this morning thanks
for taking the time to talk to us
latest figures show the number of
complaints made to ofcom
has increased by around 800 percent
over the last five years pretty
significant uh here's to tell us more
ofcom's chief executive
at dame melanie dawes at melanie great
to see you this morning um
an 800 percent rise is is reasonably
significant is it that television has
just become so egregious
over the past 12 months or that we've
all been stuck indoors watching more of
it than ever
well i think we're a nation of tv lovers
and as you say we've been watching more
of it in the last year particularly with
lockdown
and you know for the most part our
broadcasters do a brilliant job and they
get
fantastic tv and so many different
programs catering to all sorts of
different audiences
and different tastes but every now and
then people see something they don't
like
and they can complain to ofcom and
that's where we come in
so on what basis does ofcom make its
rulings you know people like me
have to spend hours and hours pouring
over the regulations to make sure that
we're doing our jobs properly but from
the
for the members of the public what are
the tests that you use
well look what we absolutely base our
decisions on um and we don't step in
lightly by the way because freedom of
speech is incredibly important but when
we do step in
the sorts of things we're thinking about
are what is the audience
um really uh interested in what do they
really care about we do a lot of
research we talk to audiences
so when i was growing up in the 70s and
80s people
really didn't like swearing on tv for
example but now they're a bit more
relaxed about it provided that we take
care around the watershed so
we really do make sure we understand
where audiences are coming from
give us an idea of some of the most
complained about pieces of television
and anything of course involving the bbc
just go straight forward
well so the kind of stuff that drives uh
the numbers and those big increases that
you were mentioning
um tends to be the shows perhaps not
surprisingly where you've got a lot of
people watching so
it's often the big very popular
entertainment show so over the decades
it's been things like i'm a celebrity
big brother coronation street even so
that's the kind of thing that drives the
big numbers in the past year the things
where we've taken action
have been for example on things like
covid where we've actually had really
bad misinformation people saying
for example that that 5g is causing
kovid and broadcasters putting that on
without any kind of challenge or context
so
that's the sort of stuff we're more
likely to take action on the more
serious harm
because we do prise freedom of speech
can you
can you put a figure on what percentage
of
complaints are actually upheld by ofcom
yeah so look we had um uh 140 000
complaints last year that was 12 000
programs and we um actually investigated
48 so it's not that many to start with
we don't step in lightly
and then about half of those um we
actually found that there'd been a
breach
um so those are that's a rough idea of
our numbers
where does ofcom intercept because of
course you know it it is one thing to be
a broadcaster on terrestrial broadcaster
through satellite but people are
broadcasting via phones
you know via desktop pcs these days what
is ofcom's role if anything
in looking at that that's a really good
point and you know increasingly of
course you've got a lot of stuff being
broadcast on the internet on social
media platforms
but what we find is that actually
viewers know that what they see on tv
can be trusted particularly when you're
thinking about things like news
and that's why i think it's so important
that we've got the rules and safeguards
because actually
british viewers do tell us that they go
to the tv when they want to know the
facts when they want the accuracy
um whereas you know they also know that
you can't always trust what you see
online
so i think actually our broadcasting
rules are a really important part of the
system
um and i have to ask you as you're here
how does the search for a chairman
going offcom i understand that paul
daker has not been best pleased with the
outcome of his interview process
well look it's the government who are in
charge of that quite rightly they get to
choose our chair so
uh it's still continuing as you say uh
well i just wanted just one
one final question are people wanting to
find out just a little bit more about
what ofcom is doing you know and the
responsibilities on
broadcasters like sky news and others
where can they go
you can go to our website we are always
we always publish as much as we possibly
can including where we don't take action
on a tv complaint we always explain
you know at least at a high level why
not so go to our website and you can
find out more about what we do
melanie dawes chief executive of welcome
good to see you this morning thanks for
being with us
thanks very much uh time to see how the
weather is looking joe's standing by in
the glass box
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
hello there good morning to you well the
weather is as they say disappointing
for the time of year still really rather
unsettled
that's not to say there isn't any
sunshine nor any warmth just that we're
also seeing some showers and longer
outbreaks of rain as well
so for today the winners and the losers
northern and western parts are seeing
more in the way of clouds some
showery outbreaks of rain there
particularly for southern parts of
ireland
central southern eastern areas seeing a
nice dry start to the day some
brightness as well
and as temperatures rise which they will
to a high of 24 or 25 degrees celsius
that's 77 degrees fahrenheit
we'll find showers breaking out and
where you get those showers they could
be heavy and slow moving particularly
over the east midlands parts of east
anglia too through the latter part of
the day those showers eventually start
to die away to give some evening
sunshine
but then we see cloud increasing down
towards the southwest and that's going
to bring some heavy rain in overnight
which will just skirt its way through
parts of south wales
reaching central southern areas by
morning and then pushing away towards
parts of kent
meanwhile central and northern parts in
the best of the sunshine but also more
of the day's showers
the weather sponsored by qatar airways